[Music]
conflict is costly for the economy
people when they think about conflict
they often think about the emotive parts
of conflict like the visceral images
that we get on television and things
like that and often the economic side
that we all benefit when there's peace
and we all lose when there's conflict is
often kind of thrown by the wayside but
we thought well maybe if we expose
people to the opportunity of trading
stocks this might make them more aware
of the kind of the gains to society and
might change their voting behavior and
their attitudes was the peace process as
well and that's exactly what we found
what we found was that being supposed to
maybe $5,200 with the stock even that
exposure for a period of four to seven
weeks was enough to change people's
attitudes to help them become more
financially literate and to change their
voting decisions in a fairly substantial
way people were really changing their
votes and their attitudes towards the
peace process based on the gains to
Israel's economy so it's really a kind
of a socio tropic thing the thing that
people were beginning to appreciate that
you know there's this common good that's
the Israeli economy stock markets
potentially are an imperfect but
nonetheless a non-partisan gauge of that
economy and and by being supposed to the
stock market they get this nonpartisan
metric for measuring and evaluating
different policies
finance I think is particularly
promising in many ways because it's
really about sharing the future this
idea of using financial instruments to
really have people share in the in the
gains from society as well as
incentivize them to work for the common
good is really a powerful idea that
isn't just restricted to firms it's also
something that you know we could do
collectively as well if we are all
invested in the market portfolio or
index funds we all benefit when the
economy benefits there's focus on the
common good this incentive to support
the common good and this nonpartisan
metric about what the common good is can
really we think be a very potent way to
mitigate polarization and conflict
[Music]
you